نعود لتطورات المدنيه جنوبيه اوكرانيا
وينضموا الي الان من ميكولايف مراسل
الجزيره تامر الصماديه مرحبا تامر ابرز
المستجدات حيث انت
صباح الخير محمد نتحدث عن هجوم صاروخي
واسع النطاق وفقا للسلطات الاوكرانيه هنا
في مقاطعه ميكولايف وفي العديد من
المقاطعات الجنوبيه هذا الهجوم انطلق فجر
اليوم من سفن متواجده متمركزه في البحر
الاسود اتواجد في احد المواقع التي تعرضت
للاستهداف فجر هذا اليوم يستطيع الزميل
المصور احمد ان يقرب لكم الصوره بشكل افضل
هذا واحد من اكبر
المراكز التجاريه التي تغذي السكان في
مدينه ميكو لايف في قلب المدينه في
الحقيقه نحن كنا نرصد طيله فجر هذا اليوم
قصفا مكثفا اصوات القصف كانت تدوي محمد في
قلب المدينه بالقرب من المكان الذي نقيم
في الدفاعات الجويه تم تفعيلها بشكل كامل
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه المتواجده هنا
في ميكولاي نيكولايف التي تتعرض لقصف يومي
متواصل في قلب المدينه وعلى اطراف وفي
المناطق الساحليه وفي المناطق ايضا
المتاخمه لخيرسون التي تتعرض لقصف متواصل
كما تشاهدون اثار وشظايا هذا القصف في كل
مكان في هذه الساحه وهذا المركز التجاري
الذي كان يعمل حتى يوم امس محمد في
الحقيقه كان يستقبل
السكان ويلبي احتياجاتهم حتى يوم امس
اليوم باتا كما تشاهدون انقاض ملقى على
الارض مدمره مهشمه في الحقيقه هذا القصف
ليس الوحيد في ميكولايب الحديث عن هجوم
صاروخي واسع من البحر الاسود وهذا
الاستهداف الذي المكان المستهدف الذي
نتواجد فيه الان هو واحد من اماكن عديده
تعرضت للاستهداف فجر اليوم ويستطيع ايضا
الزميل المصور ان ينتقل بالصوره الى الضفه
الاخرى ومن ثم يعود الى هنا ذلك المكان او
هذا المبنى هو ايضا عباره عن
لبيع المركبات لبيع السيارات وقد تعرضت
ايضا هذه الشركه المحليه كما علمنا من
الاداره ايضا للقصف فجر هذا يوم القصف
ايضا تواصل على مقاطعات قريبه من هذا
المكان نتحدث عن كيرسون نتحدث عن زبالوجيا
بالاضافه الى دينبرو قبل قليل فقط حاكم
خرسون الاوكراني تحدث عن تعرض مستشفى
بيرسلاف للقصف ايضا من قبل القوات الروسيه
وتم تدمير عدد من غرف العنايه المركزه
والحديث ايضا عن جرحى في صفوف المدنيين
وايضا تحدث عن اكثر من 80 هجوم من اكثر من
80 قصفا على المدينه وعلى طول القرى
الواقعه على خط المواجهه خط التماس بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه في خيرسون
الحديث ايضا عن قصف يطال زباروجيا اكثر من
90 هجوما منذ الليله الماضيه وحتى هذه
الساعات عديد القرى الواقعه على خط النار
خط الجبهه بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
هذا القصف محمد ياتي فقط بعد يوم واحد من
هجوم واسع النطاق تعرضت له العاصمه كييفو
عديده المقاطعات الجنوبيه الحديث بالامس
كان عن هجوم من طائرات استراتيجيه ومن
البحر الاسود الان يتكثف الحديث عن هذا
الهجوم الجديد من البحر الاسود قياده
عمليات الجنوب كانت تحدثت خلال ساعات
الصباح عن ارسال القوات الروسيه مزيد من
التعزيزات العسكريه والقطع البحريه الى
منطقه البحر الاسود تتحدث عن عديده السفن
المحمله بصواريخ كاليبر مجنحه وهذه هذا
الهجوم الذي تعرضت له ميكولايف اليوم جرى
وفقا لحاكم
نيكولايب وحاكم خيرسون ايضا بصواريخ
كاليبر مجنحه وكانت قبل قليل قبل هذا
المباشر كانت فرق الفرق المتخصصه تقوم
بازاله اج هو حطام تلك الصواريخ ايضا
تحدثت السلطات المحليه هنا فجرا ايضا عن
اسقاط الدفاعات الاوكرانيه عددا من
المسيرات الهجوم يجري على الجنوب
الاوكراني بالصواريخ
بالمسيرات ايضا وفي الحقيقه نستطيع القول
بان هنالك كثافه غير معتاده باتت تزداد
يوما بعد يوم فيما يتعلق بالقصف المتواصل
للمقاطعات الجنوبيه وذلك محمد يمكن ربطه
مع الحديث المتصاعد عن الهجوم الوشيك
المرتقب للقوات الاوكرانيه على مواقع
تمركز القوات الروسيه في خرسون فيزا
تحديدا وخيرسون القريبه من هنا بكثيرا
بطبيعه الحال هنالك من يقول بان هذا القصف
الذي يشتد شيئا فشيئا هو ياتي رد على
محاولات ربما التقدم للقوات الاوكرانيه
ومحاولات ايضا
اطلاق هذا الهجوم المضاد المرتقب هذه طيله
الايام الماضيه كان عن زبروجه وخيرسون على
واقع كل هذا القصف تزداد المواجهه يزداد
القصف والقصفه المتبادل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه في تلك المناطق في
هذه المناطق الحديث عن خيرسون تحديدا وعن
زبروجيا في الحديث عن قصف مكثف تقوم به
القوات الاوكرانيه على مناطق
المنطقه الشرقيه او الزبروج ريف زبروجي
الجنوبي عفوا التي تتواجد في القوات
الاوكرانيه الحديث عن ميليتوبل وتكماك
والحديث ايضا عن قصف متواصل لمواقع تمركز
القوات الروسيه على الضفه الشرقيه من
نهرسون الحديث منذ ايام متواصله عن عما
تسميه السلطات الاوكرانيه بتطهير الساحل
الامامي من الضفه الشرقيه لمواقع تمركز
القوات الروسيه على الضفه الشرقيه اذا
المواجهه مفتوحه والقصف والقصف المتبادل
متواصل ايضا والمناطق المدنيه ما زالت حتى
هذه اللحظه تتعرض للاستهداف المتواصل نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه التفاصيل
والمعلومات تامر الصمادي مراسله الجزيره
كنت معي من ميكولايف